[Music]
that's an answer I have a package for
you
cool thanks so you could just sign right
here on it house
I don't think loafs get haunted like
that ghosts are more of the humble
cottage type no are you doing a haunted
house for Allah ween
oh um yet yep that's what that's for
we got an eye for authenticity huh
thank you I usually set up a haunted
house in my neighborhood I can never
quite find the right balance between
realness and horror you know not really
you know that for a sec Wow this
craftsmanship is amazing hey so about
that package um getting the
heebie-jeebies just stand right here
think you could do a seminar for my
block
you know lessons for us newbies we don't
know what we're doing out there no of
course not ah I see do you got to keep
the seekers close to your chest
hey from one spooky to another's I
totally understand but almost forgot
don't hurt yourself on that thing you
have a good day sir
okay fit
yeah it's just not the hello yes yeah no
man we no longer have that in stock how
you doing today sir
oh you know slowly dying inside excuse
me I'm all right well you can order
online that's an option what pretty sure
and um it's one of you had any card
cases actually don't have a website
crazier what kind of card are you trying
to display Magic the Gathering online is
a very big term ma'am I didn't need a
website I mean I beat up on Google
myspace Facebook whatever which card is
it I just have to match the display case
of the value of the card maybe your son
doesn't deserve to have the game anyway
did you think about that a Black Lotus
what did you think a black
this is a [ __ ] leg we can no not
possible [ __ ]
sorry we need to see it highly doubt
that we get a lot of liars you could be
lying
well not and you should have no problem
showing us I'll be right back alright
okay
click question yep is it an alpha or
beta print not sure I'll let me check
I'm sure oh says it's an alpha print no
huh what the hell I'm sorry I just don't
understand how a flannel-wearing Leon
bridges looking mother person like you
have such a treasure and I'd even
understand what it's worth
first of all excuse her it's just they
only made about a thousand of these so
it's kind of a big deal hmm I guess like
25,000 is a steal right that's what I'm
making here this is just another
purchase for you isn't it excuse me yeah
we have this all the time some rich guy
comes in here because he can with his
great life in this great job and buys
the most expensive card in gaming
history you don't deserve it
anyone here is more deserving
[Music]
but just met me no idea who I am you
have no idea what I do or do not deserve
so how about you keep your half-baked
thoughts to your [ __ ] self so can we
see it by the ghost
Michael Jackson holy man my life is
complete um you guys have cases there's
actually a shipment coming in tomorrow
if you're willing to come back you can
always try to order online
[Music]
[Music]